all right our next and final speaker for
this morning
is donna august uh donna i'm not sure if
i'm pronouncing your name properly but
if i
am mispronouncing it that means i'm also
mispronouncing the name of your research
group
um so i hope that you'll clarify me if i
if i'm getting that mistake
and donna's going to be talking to us
about valuing expertise from the people
we serve
thank you can you hear me okay loud and
clear
okay terrific and i believe you all are
going to put my slides up on the screen
all right thank you for that
introduction
uh roy and thank you for thank you
community for
inviting me to be here and to
participate i've been
thoroughly enjoying the conversations
and interactions and presentations
yesterday and today and looking forward
to more
and i'm just very happy to be here
learning a tremendous amount in fact
last night i sat down and
modified my presentation based on some
of the things i learned yesterday as one
of the other presenters
said this morning too it's an ongoing
learning process and i appreciate it
so as as rory i mentioned i'm going to
speak about value valuing expertise from
the people we serve
and yes you did pronounce my name
correctly roy it's my last name is
august
and i am the founder of august research
group based in oceanside california
which is
near san diego and my email address is
donna at augustresearchgroup.com
and i encourage anyone who wants to
reach out to me with questions or
discussion beyond the setting of this
week to do so
so my slides just disappeared from the
screen
maybe you all can bring them back
so on the first slide the one that's
coming back here in a moment
there's i included a picture of myself
and there's alt texts describing me
there as well
so i'm an african-american woman i'm 62
years old
i have brown skin eye glasses and in
this photo
i have a pre quarantine short afro
and i just i describe myself and include
that description
uh with include the photo in part
because
all of us here i think have a certain
awareness of intersectionality
and the fact that we bring various
aspects of our backgrounds
experiences knowledge and and lives to
every interaction that we have and so
that gives you a little bit
of a visual of me and i'll talk a little
bit more about some of my other
other aspects of my background and
experience
as we go on the presentation we go to
the next slide second
second slide please okay
so i'm going to talk about three
projects and the slide will catch up in
just a second
the three projects are called first
attention arcade
thank you very much the second one is
notify me
and the third one is data science for
all and these are all projects that
august research group
is involved in working with different
folks in different communities
next slide please so the first one
attention arcade
for this project we're doing some
consulting with a company in san diego
called brain leap technologies
and brain leak technologies has has
looked at the challenge of how how might
we help children
strengthen their attention skills and
behind that challenge
is the question of why do children's
attention skills need strengthening or
some children's attention skills need
strengthening
in some cases it is because they
have adhd or attention challenges
that are that are diagnosed
that have been identified in some cases
they're well understood or in some cases
they're
somewhat understood some of the children
that we've
interacted with to understand attention
skills
are have autism spectrum disorder or on
the spectrum
and have challenges that go along with
their autism spectrum disorder in some
cases there are undiagnosed reasons
learning disabilities maybe parents or
children
think that there may be adhd or asd
but but that hasn't been evaluated by a
professional
in some cases the children are
disengaged from
the learning process or they're easily
distracted so there are a variety of
reasons
that attention skills need need
strengthening
next slide please
two of the founders of
two of the three founders of marine
league technologies
are neuroscience researchers at uc san
diego
dr jamie townsend and dr lan chakowski
they've done extensive research
extensive neuroscience research
over in the case of dr townsend
30 30 years in the case of dr chakowski
over 20 years
and working together they've identified
a number of methods for tracking eye
movements
to measure attention so working with
sighted children they identified a
number of areas
of gaze control to assess
and to train with with the sighted
children
in the right age range of of seven to
fourteen years old
these specific areas that they work with
for assessing and for training
are looking at fast shifts of attention
inhibitory control
and anticipatory focus
and i included a reference here citation
for one of their published papers from
2018. next slide please
so what community does this serve who
does this serve
serves children with attention
challenges
and it's extremely important to the
the team at brainleaf technologies and
and to the work that we're doing with
them
that the children's expertise is valued
in the process of designing
ways for strengthening their attention
skills
so the team did pilot research and
interviews with children
and that led to identifying an interest
in
on the children's part and having a
gamified approach
to attention training
so the team designed gaze-controlled
video games
the children can have fun playing the
games while they're training their
attention
they play the games with their eyes
instead of with a game controller or a
mouse
and this is a novel approach so there's
some fun in that
but also the children some of the
children describe it as
it's like having a superpower and they
like the fact that they can control the
games
by just using their eyes
this slide the next slide
has six of the attention arcade screens
so this these screens and the images
show
six of the games that are included in
the arcade
and each of the games now has an alt
text description
thank you for the reminders that that
was important for me to include
and while i won't go through each of the
descriptions
what i'll say collectively about the
games is that
they use that they are gaze-controlled
video games
and they use different interactive and
playful
gamified techniques for challenging the
children
to advance their skills and for
assessing and monitoring
how they do that in the following ways
the games are
in different in different ways
emphasizing fast and accurate shifts of
attention
by having the children move their eyes
quickly to
look at a target rapidly while it's
moving across the screen
inhibitory control so that there are
distracting targets that pop up say on
the periphery or edges of the screens
and those distracting targets are to be
ignored by the children with their plane
while while they're playing
instead having the children focus on the
on the items that are
the most important items to be
controlled in order to win points in the
game
the games include a challenge of holding
a steady
fixation of gaze holding the children
holding their eyes steadily on a target
for a certain length of time in order to
gain their points in that game
others have a visual search in a crowded
field
rapidly being able to pick out and
select
certain items that have high point
valuation compared to other items that
have low point or negative values
and ignoring moving distractions that's
part of the inhibitory control but also
a very specific aspect of
having those distractions be in motion
and still having the child have
sufficient attention skills to be able
to ignore that
and when they when they're able to do
that their eyes are locked on certain
targets that have
high point gain and so those are the
kinds of
systems that are set up in this gamified
application
to improve attention skills
let's go to the next slide please
so the next example that i'll give of
work that we've been doing
is notify me so this is an early stage
research and development
project and in this project we're
examining urban and workplace sounds
in environments where people cannot hear
well
the data set that we're developing the
initial data set work that we're doing
is being sponsored by in part
by the association for computing
machinery the special interest group on
computer human interaction
and in in doing this work we're
collaborating with deaf
and hearing users and having both having
individuals from both those communities
work together we're defining and
identifying
context dependent significant sounds
when i use the term significant sounds
it's pretty likely that
you may think okay wait significant that
there's a
word there that can be defined in a lot
of different ways by a lot of different
people
and that's exactly what we want we want
different individuals
to be able to define what's significant
about the sounds that are happening in
the environment around them
and raise awareness to that individual
when those significant sounds occur in
real time
so our system that we're still in the
early stages of designing
and defining will notify both deaf
and hearing users of significant sounds
based on their own definition of
significance
and they'll do that notification or the
system will do that notification via
haptic
and visual indicators on wrist wearable
devices
and some examples of those devices
include
devices such as the neo sensory buzz and
various smart watches
next slide please so in this
in this situation who are the experts
where where are we
valuing expertise from we're valuing
expertise
again from the people who we serve the
people who
we hope to have benefit from this
this intervention intervention that
we're designing
so for example one of the sources of
expertise
for notify me is a deaf adult who has
been deaf for many years
this person has expertise on staying
safe
and communicating effectively in
environments where people cannot hear
and i want to emphasize that that
because
this deaf adult who has been deaf for
many years
has developed over time enormous
expertise
in staying safe and communicating in
these environments
when we're now looking at these
environments for a different reason
for a specific reason say a noisy
workplace and how does work get done
safely
and with effective communication this
deaf person who has that expertise
is needed for us to do this work well
another source of expertise for this
project is a hearing adult
who has experience in working in noisy
workplaces
such such as industrial workplaces or
driving
in a loud truck environment and they
have expertise about which sounds are
important
for their safety and for communication
and when we combine
the expertise from those two sources we
have something that neither could give
us
independently but both can give us
together
so this code does not co-design effort
specifically disallows
a deficit model very consciously we
disallow that model
because deaf expertise is needed for
this r d
to proceed well and then
in a deficit model the deaf expertise
may be overlooked or discounted but in
this case
it's elevated and it's extremely
important for the success of the project
next slide please
so here's a here's a photo of a person
working
in a noisy workplace
this person is is um is wearing
headphones
in that noisy workplace to protect their
ears
in a noisy workplace sometimes people
are wearing
headphones to listen to music while
they're working so it could be for
safety reasons could be for
entertainment
could be to reduce the tedium of the job
but in in the in those examples this
person who
can hear is now wearing headphones that
obscure what they can hear
and so the notify me system is being
designed with the expertise of the deaf
workers and the hearing workers
in this noisy workplace example for the
use of both of them
both categories of workers would receive
notifications about significant
sounds in the workplace
next slide please the third
project that we're working on this is
one that we recently
have have joined the team for we're
doing some consulting with correlation
one
and correlation one is is a
company that does a variety of data
science and data analytics
consulting for clients who are
who are growing their businesses based
on highly leveraged use
of data the data that's relevant to
their business
a lot of businesses these days can't
find enough folks with data science
experience to fill open positions
it's a growing field there are a variety
of different roles from entry level all
the way
up to to highly experienced
roles and
finding enough folks who are both
interested in the field
and skilled in the field is a challenge
for
some of the clients that correlation one
works with and so they decided
a few years ago to start
efforts toward identifying people who
have interest in data science
and bringing them into data science
training programs and opportunities for
employment
one of the programs that they are doing
is they call data science for all
is a three-month certificate course on
introductory data analytics
it's free to the participants and it's
taught on saturdays
over the course of three months very
long saturdays i mean very long days
each saturday
but for three months with the saturday
intensives
as well as homework assignments and some
group meetings that happen during the
week in between the saturday meetings
a cohort of students travels through
this curriculum
and learns introductory data analytics
the graduates are employment ready
and the sponsors of the data science for
all
certificate courses are companies who
are interested in employing and
employing people
in these roles including entry level
folks
and so it's a good it's a very good
match for the sponsors
and the graduates of the cohort to be
able to
look at possible employment matches
the correlation one team set out to
specifically
focus on building diverse cohorts
through partnerships with
various communities of practice so for
example they partnered with the
national society of black engineers and
other organizations so that they can
specifically reach out into communities
that are underrepresented in data
science
and other areas of stem
this cohort that started in the fall of
had over 8 000 applicants and they could
only choose 500 because that was the
size
of the plan for this cohort they're
hoping to grow the program and expand it
as time goes on
this diverse 500 student cohort
is 53 female 3 other
in terms of gender and
self-identification and 44
male other examples of diversity
in this specific cohort 16 percent lgbtq
plus
30 latinx 50 percent black
and it also includes applicants who
self-identified as
in in other areas of underrepresented
communities so such
refugees immigrants people from low
income backgrounds
people with disabilities or first
generation college students
next likely part of what we are working
with
the correlation one and the data science
for all program to do
is to collaborate with deaf communities
to form the first
data science for all deaf hard of
hearing cohort for this program
this cohort will have 10 to 20 deaf
or hard of hearing participants this is
for spring 2021
and people from deaf communities such as
the national black deaf advocates
are helping us to prepare accommodations
to make sure that we are
we are trying to do our best
to help this first cohort to both be
successful themselves
and to help us to pave the way for more
deaf and hard of hearing participants
to join future cohorts going going
forward
we're developing asl signs for data
science those will be
available open access and we're
recruiting deaf teaching assistants as
part of the team
next slide please and then this is the
last slide
so these three projects all have a
common thread focus
on value and expertise from the we serve
our r d is is done in such a way that we
incorporate expertise from the users
into the design
we value the lived experiences of the
users it's not just the formal
experiences
knowledge and training but also the
lived experiences
that may not be through formal channels
we welcome all the users knowledge
and we begin our work with users input
in all ways in a number of other ways we
we strive to demonstrate and to
to actually implement the the
value valuing of expertise from the
people who we serve
thank you
thank you very much donna what what
great and inspiring work
uh that you're able to to take on um
we have a couple of questions for you
and comments um
one question asks and i think this was
about
um the arcade slides that you were
sharing uh does it require a special eye
gazer device
or is this available on webcam devices
like iphone
that's a good question it does require
a special device and in fact this is a
device i don't know if you guys
if you all can see this so this is this
is an eye tracker from
a company called toby third party it's a
usb device
plugs into a usb port on a windows
compute
windows computer and the eye tracking
is is done in by this device in
conjunction with our software
great um we have a comment from serene
jacquez
who's the founder of death codes kids
and said that they'd be happy to
collaborate with you
wonderful absolutely wonderful we have
another question
um with such a high graduation rate from
the
ds4a program what have been the
indicators for successful transition to
employment
uh that's a very good question so
as you can imagine the correlation one
team is is big on data
you know collecting data about the the
the each cohort
how it how they how the cohort travels
through the curriculum
and placement into jobs as well as
retention
so retention is key and retention has is
multifaceted
it's not just sort of time and position
after
joining a company but it's also
satisfaction
and fulfillment in the in the role in
the job with opportunities for
growth and continued career development
so all of those are the kinds of metrics
that the team
monitors and seeks to continue to have
feedback from
with each cohort as they graduate and
move into various data science roles
and we'll continue to as well so this
cohort this diverse cohort of this fall
that just started in october will be
completing
their 13 weeks because we don't meet
over a couple of holiday weeks
they'll completely be completing their
13 weeks at the beginning of february
and so at that point many of them will
move into
new positions and we'll be keeping track
of that data
and seeing how well we do in retention
and
job satisfaction great
thank you um it looks like that's all
the questions that we have for donna
uh donna thank you very much for sharing
um your work
as i said it's really really great stuff
thank you you're welcome
um and so it looks like we're going to
be finishing a few minutes early
so that will give people a few more
minutes to stretch their legs
hopefully we'll see all of you back here
in your uh
breakout group you should have the
proper link for those breakout groups in
your calendar or have received an email
from msr events or genus
about the breakout groups so uh
enjoy your short break and please join
us
and join your breakout groups back here
at 10 45 pacific time
thanks
you